hey youtube
markiplier here I've been training all
year for the YouTube to calf one as you
can see the production quality on my
videos has gone up tremendously I blame
my training I'm awesome and you're
awesome for getting me to four hundred
thousand subscribers and as you can see
I'm not gonna quit I'm gonna train
harder than ever like it right like this
I'm a trained in the city that I'm in
and I'm gonna be running away from this
damn Nietzsche monster and I'm gonna be
better than I ever was before so just
your way
for the next hundred thousand
subscribers it's gonna be even better
than it was before so if you been paying
attention I made some changes that's the
old me I'm running away from that I'm
gonna be better than I ever was before
so king of the squirrels get going king
of the bike is online I'm the greatest
and you're great for watching me you
guys are the best fans ever and you've
been pushing me to be the best youtuber
ever so I'm not gonna quit so thanks for
believing me and stick around for more
awesome videos cuz I'm gonna win
you